your favorite chick advice first of all
I'm telling the grill reason why we're
using the thighs I either browned eat it
so it doesn't go dry season applies salt
pepper olive oil and turn them over pigs
don't get your hands in there good don't
worry about your nail varnish so no
bones in there so the chicken will cook
really quickly
why'd you get inside dang it skin side
down first that'll stop the chicken from
go and dry and I'll get it really nice
and crispy
get away smart the skin there so all
that really nice flavor in there as well
tell them every two or three minutes how
much do you love chicken slap Lots you
serve that some really nice chick peas
first of all to make a little dressing
okay
one nice teaspoon of mustard in please
no bit of olive oil and touch of salt
and pepper give that really good mix
and then just squeeze lots of lemon
juice in there a little tasting
that is delicious
now
hello beautiful nice and crispy as well
sound the gas down now and leave that
chicken the griddle
right lift it and chickpeas done Shelly
so got vigilia peppers so these are
roasted smoked Spanish peppers now
little taste
like you chop up the heavy berries you
take off three the top gonna slice them
in half like that
what's your fingers okay so these are
small poquito peppers yeah
for this sweeter there you go you think
it's too please what's your famous
please tuck them in three things a rule
come on Holly you know the three finger
rule I'll be telling that since six
months old
good girl you're fast honey you're
faster than Jack don't tell him go get
em upstairs yes please thank you yes
then give it a little mix for your
fingers Thanks come on out get out
every time this food is always there he
smells it from mile away
brilliant stinks like damn why is it on
inside that piece is really nice and
moist but fine
now feta cucumber and nice and hot
get the feet comps okay and just break
them up I'm gonna start slicing there
was a minute okay
yeah these are fine this they just made
these little boats and go around like
that now with the toasted you can give
them a little season with you please
no just touch a salt thank you the
golden round you just start seeing smoke
insane now turn the gas off please
we're just gonna take half the cucumber
and give that a little peel for me
please that's a nicely dry roasted take
them off so from there don't want you
then to slice around the seeds
that's the watery part I came to keep
that out special fingers please nice
I still faster than Jack you are still
very fast a lot faster than Jack now
cucumber on top of the melon will mix up
in a minute to give that a nice little
like seasoning touch of salt and I'll
touch your pepper please across the
reason for its pecans in there phone
nice next Greek feta cheese this is kind
of easy isn't it Jack love snowing okay
hurry up may take him out fat lazy lump
snoring his head off
come on out so got that nice juicy melon
the cucumber and now the cheese we need
something to bring it to life no taste
that's soo maggot okay that is very
citrusy we're just gonna season that
lightly no I want you to do it sprinkle
the pecans in there mm-hmm what's that
basil mint mint mint tea fine they get
confused a battle you boyfriend no daddy
okay good keep it that way for ten years
fresh mint over and then a little
drizzle of olive oil
okay don't mix it yet I know you're
dying to get there early mm-hmm I'm just
some fresh lemon juice
why do you really miss that mister
release all the juice it's now feel it
so it's less firm lil bit more Scotty no
it's all that lemon juice coming out
what to do
[Music]
what do you taste everything yummy it's
fresh isn't it hmm so that's the salad
damn horse I'll take the chicken now
can't you see that is see what we to do
now with a basil yeah Mr Gatley Glee's
just tear them in there there you go
start lifting particulate please and
putting it in the chickpeas Oh juicy
amazing chicken remember this little
baby here a vinaigrette the heat of the
chicken could infuse the basil because
the chickens nice and warm melts the
basil and turn this salad into something
really delicious smell so nice so you've
glazed the chicken
slide it onto our plate how gorgeous is
that got a roasted pepper flavor fresh
basil there's wonderful chickpeas with a
caper berries do you think jack will
like this you think Jack would like this
one yeah yeah I'm Megan until even
really interesting let's go well done
[Music]
this is my ultimate light dinner griddle
chicken thighs with chickpeas and a
lemony dressing
better and watermelon salad yeah yeah
Maggie
Tilly let's go
[Music]
scale of one to ten how easy is this ten
you doing it again excellent great
colors beautiful colors she's pretty
good with a knife yeah faster than Jack
Jackie word you're being taken over by
your twin tails how was it mmm meg is it
the kind of dish you can see cooking for
a boyfriend one day no I remember the
first dish your mother anything for me
what
[Music]